how scum raise mine is pure welcome to
today we are going to take a look in the
past I've seen so many of you bros
digging into my old pictures on my own
Facebook profile I don't know why you do
that my only guess is you're trying to
figure out how the hell did he become
this fabulous so I thought I'd share
with you my experiences from the past I
haven't seen these pictures in forever
so III don't think I even seen a lot of
these pictures at all
I love crackers then and I love crackers
now baby Oh dad pose hello
is this right natural born model baby
there you go I don't need to show
anymore I almost have to censor this for
YouTube I'm so ugly I look like a little
troll for some reason my hair was white
when I was younger and I'm stuck with
this oh that's me and my mom look she's
so beautiful
I can't show this no oh my haircut I
think I got this TV for my birthday but
it doesn't look new cos old dusty and
[ __ ] what is that what are we playing it
looks like Super Mario doesn't it the
end did I beat the game and I'd be like
yeah what's up gotta take a picture a
device that will get all the ladies that
I'll never get that's what I had a lot
of people say me and my dad look very
similar and I think they're right he
literally has the same glasses as I have
now like what the hell this is some
really sexy [ __ ] I don't know if I can
show this to your breasts I'm so fat oh
hello I'm like loving the picture and my
sister's like yeah he's so annoying can
he go away and I'm like oh yeah
obviously I had a great sense of fashion
back then I clearly know I knew what was
in style and what wasn't
apparently cornflakes packages was very
popular I didn't know I was a doctor
back then and that's impressive
look at
I don't know how old I am at this but I
don't think I'm that young pieces I
don't want to look oh god now my
sister's is like don't worry I'll kill
him for you you don't have to take care
of him anymore I'm so surprised by
something the horror game talent started
already back then that is so typical my
dad I really look good in that moustache
I should I should get that oh god oh god
no this is so embarrassing seriously
what am i doing to that snow this is
gonna be on the internet forever
yeah oh god stop oh god Steph oh this is
the first day of school let's just look
so cute rocking that guitar oh yeah
still still I have the problem keeping
my head up for some reason
oh god no spike what's the thing okay
it was the 90s alright it was cool
I was I was hip don't question it just
do you go with it oh god that's even
better this is second grade we jump and
I remember I was allergic to ketchup so
I look like that on the picture that
haircut was so good the bowl hit bowl
haircut you can't beat that I need to
get a haircut now but I think I might
get it just to bring it back we're
bringing it back this is first grade
it's out kill hashtag skill there's me
figuring out how to open a window for
the first time and I'm very pleased by
it this is me trying to close the window
for the first time I'm on a horse oh
that's my granddad that's my cousin oh
that's so cute he passed away not long
ago and that's my sister this is a cute
picture I like it
that's god damnit you're not get
goddamnit wait buddy buddy buddy what
are you doing here why am I wearing this
why was my mom allowing this oh Jesus
that's wacky man oh damn
those glasses it started early that's my
dad as Santa Claus I'm still struggling
with this whole head thing how to keep
it up we're looking good model parrots
Ralph Lauren camera Oh God take it away
that's my first optimist yalla I don't
know what it's called in English Oh God
now we're getting that's when puberty
happened I guess Jesus
when was this baby I was 17 for some
reason I was going bald I barely have
any hair I remember I used to just fall
asleep I would like do this and I would
I would I was balding from it I guess I
remember it was a big problem but I
don't care yeah I had you speak future
sex offender start cat before he got all
fat and annoying Oh to me when I was fat
what is this I can't put this on
youtubes
goddamnit what the hell whose outfit is
that who approved of this mom why did
you take these pictures you're supposed
to say no well at least I didn't pick
the Roses one I don't know which one is
words to be on it this is going oh
that's such a cute what that nice
picture nice peach look how happy this
should be a meme reception what is that
is that even it's my birthday look how
happy I am
and we're back all right
that's cute I don't know if this was
entertaining for you brother it was it
was a lot of fun for me but I feel like
you brought a little bit piece of family
so I hope you enjoyed anyway go ahead
and leave it like me you because I
freakin shared the most embarrassing
things ever so you better it's a guy
come over today I see you bros in the
next one say awesome love you boys
I forgot to mention me until we turn
those shots forever ago a video of us
dancing together playing just dance so
check it then I can description to watch
that right now